what we doing now it hurt my heart man
but we gotta go look at some schools
some culture man
of the school man three schools back to
back back to back cardi b and offset's
three-year-old daughter culture is
almost old enough to go to school and
the whole thing has the proud parents in
their feels is she so cute i love her on
monday the up rapper explained on her
insta story that she and her hubby had a
busy morning ahead of them in new york
visiting potential schools for their
little girl mommy's best friend yeah
and offset he's pretty serious about the
process we gotta make sure
they're right school because she get the
right education we're not playing about
that we already saw two schools
well i went he was on facetime
[Laughter]
but i was there
right all right wish us luck guys and
the 28 year old grammy winner revealed
the whole thing is a lot tougher than
she expected this is the hard part i
thought it was going to be easier like
oh yeah you're going to look for schools
oh look at the school right there
everything happy life
of course cardi and offset are expecting
baby number two together and on monday
morning the proud mama shared this sweet
clip of her little one moving around in
her belly
all day
and offset not only has he been there
for all the school visits he's been by
cardi's side for all the doctor
appointments too
how to see your stinky butt stinky butt
proud to see your stinky butt
so sleepy
cardi recently shared that clip and just
look how happy offset seemed when he saw
their little one on the sonogram oh yes
honey as for culture she's already the
sweetest big sister on the block and her
sibling hasn't even been born yet
no baby sleeping
last week cardi shared that clip of her
little girl as she tried to give the
baby growing in her belly a toy
yeah baby sleeping because the turtle
baby later okay
and cardi she's taking the whole
pregnancy in stride talking pregnancy
cravings barbecue sauce barbecue meat
grilled meat is a real fat
craving
baby and showing off her sweet baby bump
in the music video for her new collab
with lizzo rumors
that's the machine nobody listen they're
buying them streams
and when it comes to being a mom the new
york native told et back in 2019 that it
means everything to her
what does it mean to be a mother it
means everything it's it's like a
feeling that it's indescribable
it's like
love joy it's a
switch
you know what i'm saying it's like an
automatic smile it's everything
you